ايه ده مشاهدينا نحن الان في فصل الصيف في
فصل الصيف دائما تمتلئ ارفف المحلات
التجاريه والصيدليات بالعشرات من الخيارات
لوقيات الشمس كل منها يعد بان يكون الافضل
في حمايه البشر من اشعه الشمس الضاره ولكن
السؤال هل هو فعلا كذلك
يبدو ان 25% فقط من واقيات الشمس مطروحه
في الاسواق توفر حمايه جيده على نطاق واسع
دون مكونات كيميائيه مزعج هذا بحسب تقرير
لمجموعه
غير الربحيه اختبرت فيه من 1700 منتج من
منتجات الحمايه من اشعه الشمس المنتجات في
التقرير صنفت من واحد الى عشره من حيث
الامتثال لاربع فئات رئيسيه هي مستوى
الحمايه من الاشعه فوق البنفسجيه الطويله
والمتوسطه
بشكل منف صل وكذلك التوازن بين الاثنين
وثبات المكونات الفعاله
[موسيقى]
يمكن
للمصنعين اضافه علامه التصديق الخاصه اذا
كانت منتجات الحمايه من الشمس تستوفي
المعايير الصارمه المعتمده طبعا
طول على علامه التصديق الدوليه يجب ان
يكون المنتج كمان اخضر وان يكون غير مضر
بالصحه او البيئه ويجب ان يذكر كل مكون
على العبوه يجب ان لا يحتوي واقي الشمس
على مكونات محظوره من قبل الاتحاد
الاوروبي او كندا بالاضافه الى اداره
الغذاء والدواء الامريكيه ووكاله حمايه
البيئه الامريكيه والبرنامج الوطني
الامريكي للسموم وقائمه كاليفورنيا للمواد
المعروفه المسببه للسرطان والسموم
الانجاب يجب ايضا الا يستخدم واقي الشمس
مشاهدينا مزاعم تسويق محظوره من قبل اداره
الغذاء ودواء الامريكيه لا يمكن ايضا ان
يكون على شكل رذاذ او بودره بسبب خطر
الاستنشاق يجب ان يحتوي المنتج على عام
الحمايه الشمس اس بي اف بين خمسه عشر
وخمسين يجب ان يوافق على تقديم نتائج اداء
الاشعه فوق البنفسجيه من مختبر مستقل بذلك
معنا الان مشاهدينا في الاستوديو اختصاصيه
الامراض الجلديه والتجميل دكتوره دينا
سمير اسماعيل اهلا بك دكتوره دينا معنا في
صباح العربيه تفضلي طيب اذا دكتوره هذه
الدراسه او على الاقل يعني هذا البحث
يتحدث عن انه فقط 25% من واقيات الشمس
الموجوده في الاسواق هي امنه للاستخدام
وفعلا فعاله هذا بيعني بانه 75% من
المنتجات غير فعال طب احنا احنا يعني
مستهلكين كيف بنقدر نفرق فعليا ما بين ما
هو غث او سمينه بصي مبدئيا كده احنا لازم
الاول نتعرف على
انواع السنبله يعني اللي هو البيزكل اللي
هو اللي هو الواقي الشمسي الفيزيائي وفي
الواقي الشمسي الكيميائي والحاجات اللي
انتم ذكرتوها اللي هي
الحاجات اللي انتم ذكرتوها زي الاوكسي
بنزون والحاجات اللي هي زي برده
الحاجات دي موجوده في الملي في الواقي
الشمسي الكيميائي بس دلوقتي مع تطور
التكنولوجي احنا في سنه دي مع دلوقتي بقت
في نسبه بنسبه قليله جدا في الكاميكا بس
يعني مبدئيا برضو احنا عايزين نعرف الناس
ان حاجه ضروريه جدا ان هي لازم ان احنا
نستعملها مع برضو قدوم الصيف وكده فدلوقتي
احنا مع اشعه الشمس
انا اختار اذا كنت اجهل كل هذه المكونات
ماذا تفعل اروح الصيدليه او اروح
الجمعيه من على الرف اختار لواقي شمسي
واذهب طيب احنا مبدئيا كده انا عايزه بس
اعرف الناس المبدئيا احنا بنختار على حسب
برده حاجه اسمها اللي هي الالترا فوالد او
اليوفي بي اي وبي مبدئيا اشعه الشمس بتطلع
لنا حاجه اسمها اشعه فوق البنفسجيه بتتكون
من ايه وبي وسي احنا هنتكلم مين ليه
مش بتوصل لنا
البي اللي هي بتعمل لنا
اليو في بي هي اللي بتعملها الاحمرار او
حروق الشمس ودي بتبقى طول الموجه بتاعها
من من 270 315 اليو بي اي هي دي بتبقى
بتوصل طبقات عميقه في الجلد الطول الموجي
بتاعها بيبقى من
315 ل 400 فدي بتعمل لنا زي شيخوخه
المبكره وبتعمل لنا تصبغات وتعمل لنا
الالماني
تجاعيد وتصبغات وكمان سرطانات الجلد طيب
دلوقتي احنا لما نيجي نختار بنختار معظم
الناس تيجي تختار بطريقه تشوف بس ده مش
كافي ان الاس اس بي اف هنا باختصاره له
بروتاكشن فاكتور واحنا قلنا دلوقتي ان
اللي مسؤول عن
الالترا بواليس هو ميلي اللي هو الاشعه
فوق البنفسجيه بي فمين اهلك دلوقتي
اه
فاهمني دلوقتي احنا محتاجين ان احنا تحمي
نفسنا من الاثنين الصيفي ايه واليوفي بي
فلما نيجي نختار مش هنختار بس على اساس
انه الاس بي اف لا لازم نختار انه يبقى
بروتس يعني اس بي اف ويبقى مكتوب كمان على
العلبه يعني بيحمينا من الاشعه
تاني ولكن حبيت اسالك هيك بيبيعوا جوله
ايضا الاطفال نفس متطلبات يعني نفس
الاطفال
والبشره الحساسه والناس اللي عندها تلجا
للفيزيكال صن بلوك اللي هو بيبقى مللي
السمبلوك باساسه ومعادن يبقى اساسه زي
الزنك اوكسايد
بالضبط فهما دول اكتر ان احنا نستخدم لهم
بشكرك جزيل الشكر ايضا اختصاصيه الامراض
الجلديه والتجميل الدكتوره دينا سمير
اسماعيل شكرا
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات